okay so imagine you're a small-time
twitch streamer and one day you realize
that some random dude and you're chad is
stream sniping you so naturally you
report him and then give them van but
then you realize that this same dude who
you don't know mass reports you using
multiple different fake accounts and you
end up with a two week twitch band and
then on top of that he admits that he's
done this before and then if you don't
play with him live on stream once you're
unbanned
he's gonna continue doing this yeah this
one is weird okay
so meet a Duras he's the streamer caught
up in all this mess a tourist lives in
Malaysia and he makes his living
streaming League of Legends primarily to
American audiences quick thing about
Malaysia is one USB is for ringing
that's the name of our currency for
ringgit so i've 0 followers my first
week on twitch I made I made a quarter
of what I made in that entire month from
my job when I worked the most hours so
yeah keep that in mind
adder is his full-time gig is streaming
on Twitch in early November a Duras was
streaming to his regular audience and he
matched up against another Malaysian
player named leis afterwards lathes hits
up a dress on discord they played one
other match together and then naturally
a dress went back to solo queue and
didn't think anything of it you know
what I played a game with him and I was
like dude good game man I'm gonna go
back to Seoul of you that was it next
time I log on to three days later he
comes by every day an arrest just
basically assumes that this leis guy is
just an eager fan and he explained to me
that this isn't really unusual because
since Malaysia doesn't really have any
big-time celebrities fans latch on to
anything they could get even small-time
twitch streamers ladies jumped in to
addresses public discord server he hung
out in his twitch chat and even asked
address to help him pick up women which
is strange but for the most part
everything seemed fine but then a dress
caught lei stream sniping one of his
league matches just a few days later and
that's where [ __ ] went seriously
sideways the
enemy team and I'm like I didn't notice
until like he was really beating us yo
dude I what a thing about me is I get
pretty tilted I won't lie it when I lose
lb I get pretty annoyed um some like yo
do you serious man you actually ghosted
my map
I was I was pre angry but I never
threatened the sky never worst thing I
called him was a dumb virgin so I was
like this is the virgin that is stream
sniping me I said that to my chat it's
for content okay yes actually and then
halfway through a stream address got
booted from twitch and ultimately hit
with that two-week twitch ban now
obviously at this point iris is freaking
the [ __ ] out because twitch is his main
source of income and he doesn't really
know what he did wrong and then over on
YouTube he gets these two random DMS
from an unnamed person and they reads
how does it feel to get banned on Twitch
kid and I can do this over and over
again so then back on this chord ley
starts DMA addresses friends try to
figure out where this guy lives and then
Adar's his friends naturally reach out
to him and say that some weirdo is
pseudo stalking him and then and I'm not
[ __ ] kidding here leis admits to mass
reporting him in their DMS okay so let's
be clear here this random dude wanted to
play with his favorite streamer so badly
he got him twitch band when he wouldn't
and then admit it to the whole [ __ ]
thing on discord and it turns out that
blaze made a bunch of different fake
accounts some of which were literal
gibberish like [ __ ] banging your head
off the keyboard gibberish and then he
reported a Duras using those accounts
and the best part about this is is when
a Duras managed to jump on a discord
call with leis and blaze just explains
exactly why he did this what do you want
me to say I want you to say that you're
not gonna mess with me anymore you know
you're not gonna report my [ __ ] again
like in one condition you gotta play
with me the only the only way for you to
not report my channel this is for me to
play with you if any idea how psychotic
that sounds dude
I'm trying to be nice here man but you
are blowing my mind is this legit just
want to have friends men oh yeah this
isn't how you make friends dude this is
how you make people hate you Jesus
Christ I mean on one hand this is super
creepy but on the other you know I kind
of feel for leis that dude just wanted
to make a friend you know but then I
learned that blaze has done this to
multiple people in the past and of
course he admitted that in the discord
call how many how much you must you do
this to you and how many times did
actually work every day holy [ __ ] even
when they came back and you did it again
did it work
you know I stole okay are you gonna stop
with me yeah could you play with me but
if I say no we'll see then apparently he
made a fake Twitter account so he could
continue DMing address and then on top
of that ladies also bragged to his
friends about how he keeps [ __ ] with
this dude
okay so let's just recap this insanity a
small-time league streamer meets this
random dude in his twitch chat they
share a weird but brief friendship until
the random dude stream Snipes the
streamer and then he bans him from his
twitch chat then this random guy makes a
bunch of fake accounts gets the streamer
banned for two weeks on Twitch and then
he cops to it all on a discord call and
the reason he did it was because he
wanted to make a friend no obviously
stream sniping is nothing new in the
world of twitch I mean everybody from
ninja to doctor disrespect has to deal
with this [ __ ] it's almost annoying
how often it happens at this point
back in my day we use different streams
now for 12 hours a day just to get a
couple kill John debate for Egypt we
would never finish the game Irwin please
we would back out queue up again but I
thought this story was worth bringing to
you because it's just that insane and at
the end of the day this is a small-time
streamer Idris is the main person
supporting his family financially this
situation completely [ __ ] up his
livelihood now after all of this I
really wanted to talk to lase just to
see if there was another explanation for
all of this and when I talked to him he
just flat-out denied the whole thing and
strangely wished me a belated happy
birthday my [ __ ] birthday is in April
after all this nonsense adder is
obviously DM delays and said hey dude
you completely [ __ ] up my career and
then in true weirdo fashion that could
only happen with a story like this Lay's
DM to address a few days later and said
hey man if you want to queue up I'm just
[ __ ] amazing I just I don't know
I just want to run through a wall of
your time and put them on oh they're
garbage I don't I don't argue the fact
that they're good bad they're not good I
just I don't know [ __ ] 10 year-old
Devin like something